hi my name is Chris P I'm a developer
advocate on the Google cast team in this
episode of dev bytes I'm going to cover
some of the essentials of creating a
cast web sender app that runs in Chrome
currently the Google cast SDK is
available for three platforms Chrome
Android and iOS in this video I will
focus exclusively on the SDK for Chrome
in order to build a Google cast web
sender application you will need to
install the Google Chrome browser and
the Google cast Chrome extension
if you already have chrome installed
make sure you are on version 32 or
higher to get the cast extension visit
the Google Chrome Web Store and search
for google cast the cast extension is
what allows web centers to communicate
with cast receivers with chrome
installed and the cast extension ready
to go let's take a peek at the cast
sender lifecycle for a moment once a
cast sender application has been loaded
the Apple detected initialized the cast
api's get notified about available
receivers connect to a receiver and
begin exchanging messages over the
established connection closing out the
life cycle is disconnection from a
receiver device let's take a closer look
at each phase of the lifecycle chrome
sender applications are constructed
using HTML javascript and CSS sender
apps can be hosted locally during
development and then moved to production
servers when publishing a Google hosted
cast sender JavaScript resource provides
the API that your sender application
uses to communicate with the cast
extension which manages the interaction
with cast receivers a chrome sender
application must detect and initialize
the cast API before communicating with
the cast receiver prior to using the
cast API is the web sender application
needs to first check that they are
available this is accomplished by
looking for the existence of chrome cast
JavaScript namespace and checking the
chromecast dot is available boolean flag
depending on how the web sender
application loads its resources it may
need to set up a retry timeout to detect
the cast api's with the detection out of
the way the web sender application is
now ready to initialize the cast API
initialization connects
web sender to the cast extension and
let's the extension know that the web
app is cast enabled performing the
initialization consists of creating a
send a request object that holds the
application ID of the receiver that will
launch then constructing a new API
config object which takes the session
request object as well as a session
listener and receiver listener callbacks
lastly the web sender calls the
chromecast initialize function and
provides the API config object along
with the success and ere call back when
the success callback is invoked the web
application has successfully initialized
the cast api's however there is one more
thing that the application needs to wait
on before proceeding
looking at the API config instructor the
receiver listener passed in performs an
important role in the discovery of cast
devices cast web sender applications
delegate the management of available
cast receiver devices to the cast
extension the API config that the app
creates is passed along to the cast
extension and the receiver listener is
invoked the receiver listener is passed
a string parameter that should be
checked for the available value any
other values should be treated as no
receiver devices available the receiver
listener will be invoked whenever there
is a change in the availability of
receiver devices the web sender should
display the cast icon when the receiver
listener reports cast receivers are
available now that the application knows
when to show a cast icon to the user we
can explore how to request a session on
a cast receiver device it's actually
quite simple the sender can call on
chromecast request session and provide a
success in air callback the success
callback will be passed a cast session
object that can be decorated with update
listeners the session card success
callback is dependent on user action and
may not be invoked let's take a look
use the receiver listener as a way to
determine if the web sender application
should show the cast icon to the user
when the user clicks the cast icon the
cast extension will show a list of
available cast receiver devices that can
be connected to by the sender if the
user closes the list without selecting a
device
the request session air callback will be
invoked otherwise if the user selects a
cast receiver device then the extension
will communicate with the cast receiver
to set up a communication channel once
complete the success callback of the
request session function will be invoked
with the connection established the
sender application may now communicate
with the connected cast receiver
application messages are exchanged
between the sender and receiver using
namespaces also called protocols these
messages are used to invoke behaviors on
the receiver application and to update
the sender application as to the state
of the receiver app one example of
message exchange would be to load some
media onto the cast receiver the cast
API is come bundled with a media API
that enables a sender app to tell the
receiver to load and playback media such
as video in this case the media info
object gets created that bundles the
information about the media this object
is then used to create a load request
object that gets passed to a session
function called load media the load
media function serializes the data and
communicates with the receiver
application over the media namespace
sender and receiver applications must
agree on the supported namespaces in
order to communicate with each other the
last part of life cycle is the
disconnection from a receiver when a
session first is first established the
session app is passed a session object
adding an update listener to the session
object allows the sender app to know
when a session has ended the session
listener function has passed a boolean
value if this value is false then there
is no connection the user can initiate a
disconnect by clicking the cast
extension and choosing stop casting this
will trigger a session update listener
when the session is torn down and there
you have it the life cycle of a cast web
sender we're very excited to see what
you build with Google cast to get you
going we are providing a number of
resources you can discover more about
the details of the google cast sdk at
developers.google.com/plus we'll go a
long way in guiding you down the path to
creating great second screen
applications you can find sample cast
sender and receiver apps at github comm
slash google cast you stackoverflow
questions and comments tag them with
Google - passed in future Deb bites we
will dive deeper into the cast sender
SDK for each platform and the cast
receiver SDK join the Google cast
developer community on Google+ for pro
tips and share your experiences it's now
up to you to go out and create great
Chrome web sender applications happy
casting